oui ce n'était pas la première fois en
réalité que Wagner avait
réclamé le contrôle de la ville de
bakkout mais c'est la première fois que
le Kremlin a réagi on félicitant ces
hommes et on affirmant que effectivement
la Russie avait pris la contrôle de la
totalité de pac-mouth alors les Russes
sont allés un peu plus loin dans leurs
affirmations les Ukrainiens sont restés
plus ou moins sur la même ligne en
disant effectivement la situation
abaquemout et difficile et les Russes
contre une grande partie de la ville
mais la ville n'est pas complètement
perdue ce qui veut dire que il y a des
forces ukrainiennes qui tiennent
certaines positions dans backmouth mais
les Ukrainiens reconnaissent en réalité
que la partie de la ville qui contrôle
est en train de se réduire
progressivement aujourd'hui c'est Hannah
vice-ministre de la Défense qui en a
parlé elle a dit que quelques
entreprises et quelques résidences dans
le quartier du sud-ouest de la ville en
quartier qui s'appelle le quartier de
l'avion reste au contrôle des Ukrainiens
seulement ces endroits là je me souviens
très bien en fait de cet avion c'est un
monument en forme d'avion qu'on voit
juste à l'entrée de batmouth quand on
arrive de l'Ouest en revanche les
Ukrainiens ont fait des progrès au sud
et au nord de batmouth donc pas la ville
même mais ils ont repoussé les Russes à
l'extérieur de la ville ce qui rendrait
je pense plus difficile encore pour les
Russes d'essayer d'avancer plus loin
au-delà de Batman
Gulliver revenons peut-être sur cette
attaque nocturne qui vient d'être menée
sur ni pro selon l'armée ukrainienne 4
missiles de croisière
vendronne d'attaque ont été détruits par
la défense entière
oui mais les Ukrainiens disent que 16
missiles de croisière ont été tirés ce
qui veut dire que 12 ont atteint leur
cible c'est bien plus que la moyenne ce
qui laisse peut-être penser que ni pro
est moins bien protégé que Kiev par
exemple ou d'autres endroits en Ukraine
les ukrainien ne donne pas beaucoup
d'informations sur les cibles qui ont
été atteints ce qui laisse penser que
c'est probablement des cibles militaire
pour la plupart mais il y aurait aussi
une caserne de pompiers qui aurait été
frappée et 8 civils qui auraient été
blessées selon les autorités
ukrainiennes sur place
en direct de Kiev merci à vous gunivers
pour ce point terrain à l'image de